Jose and I are looking at the email the
things we can't eat can't eat eggs oh I
[Music]
really like any type of food except for
like really really vegetable Hanabi food
I'm not used to looking at labels and
get like a lot of knowledge and the like
what goes into foods and if you complain
my diets better after this and hopefully
I learn how to cook something I've just
been on this like journey of having like
healthy relationships with myself food
and exercise and I'm just excited to
like start something new and do it and
that healthy positive mental space we're
going on our first grocery mission I
don't know what to look for maybe we'll
just go to what we normally get and then
look for options I made it to the fruit
section which we can guarantee is beacon
I found some mate listen
I'm here for sausage not in my sexual
life just in this life we're going for
the safe option safe option probably not
that healthy but alright let's try this
vegan sausage put some mustard on it
that's vegan to consistency a little
questionable but taste very good oh my
god actually kind of tastes like sausage
we have a little meeting today and
here's all the food that I can eat
alright so we had catered lunch today
and there was tons of sandwiches all of
which had meat except one and as tofu I
do not like tofu but I'm sticking it out
today Oh me and my friend were talking
and she's vegan she was saying how like
she gets annoyed when people do this
[ __ ] because he will like starve and
just don't end up eating because they
can't eat anything and so I've really
been making it a priority to make sure
I'm not starving and I'm not I feel very
full and I'm eating vegetables and I'm
eating fruits and I feel good so I'm
facetiming my boyfriend and he's eating
eggs I'm really jealous that looks
really good right now
so today I realized that not all vegan
food is healthy I know that's kind of
dumb to realize I snacked a lot
I had Oreos I had chips there was a lot
of things you can't eat when you're
vegan and not all of them are great for
you so I think from now on I kind of
just need to watch myself make sure I'm
just getting like the nutrients I need
so it's about 2:30 a.m.
usually right now I would make an egg
sandwich with cheese but I can't
so my lunch today is sausage list
sausage and broccoli I'm at the mall and
I keep smelling Wetzel's freakin
pretzels and I can't eat it and it's
killing me we are on our way to go to an
all vegan restaurant we're here we look
at the menus the best part of this is
that we can just choose whatever
[Music]
so after being vegan for a week I've
realized that it's truly like [ __ ]
amazing got meatless meat options it
still made me feel like I was eating me
but I felt better about it honestly
because I knew I wasn't eating animals I
think it really just opened my eyes to
the fact that like I just need to start
reading my labels of the things I eat
because honestly the things not even are
good to eat that don't have vegan stuff
in it I'm like oh my god they have this
amount of sugar and other things that I
should be looking at and paying
attention to I'm really glad I did this
challenge and from that one I can
definitely see myself exploring a lot
more options on the food so yes I will
be continuing some vegan habits but also
yes I am driving to Korean barbecue at
this very moment
[Applause]
I just say today
[Music]